hey this is Stephen Curry and this is
wired autocomplete interview alrighty
[Music]
what is Stephen Curry's highest scoring
game 62 points in the NBA a couple years
ago there was a lot of chatter just
around you know post Championship run
reality of you know our new team in
roster and house being defended and all
that I heard it all and then had the
game of my life felt like I couldn't
miss what is Stephen Curry's favorite
kind of play oh that's a good question
sounds like a game-winning shot I'd say
probably like a four-point play you know
getting fouled on three-point line and
knocking down a shot because I get to do
my account and I have a little fun with
it what is Stephen Curry's vertical jump
that is a great question that I don't
even know if I know the answer to I
think back in 2009 when I went through
the pre-draft combine I think it was
like 28 32 maybe it doesn't really
matter now I played below the rim what
does Steph Curry eat before a game it's
usually like a little grilled chicken
some pasta a couple of veggies it's way
better when I Asia Cooks it though you
know just try to have a little bit of
protein carving some veggies and get get
ready for the game usually like three
hours before the game what song does
Stephen Curry listen to before games it
depends on my mood I have a playlist
that is probably like an hour long that
has all type of music it's got some rap
some r b some Christian rap some gospel
some country it's got literally
everything on there but I would say Lupe
Fiasco and LeCrae are like the two
featured artists on most of my pre-game
playlists
foreign
Curry is called Chef this is a very Hot
Topic at our house so I get the nickname
Chef Curry Drake dropped the first line
Chef curry with the pot which is
obviously a call to me kind of cooking
them up on the court the real Chef Curry
is Aisha Curry borrow the nickname every
once in a while I'm on the court but
she's a real Chef Curry why Steph Curry
is underrated growing up in the game I
was always you know the skinniest kid on
the on the court it's a three-star
recruit didn't really get all the major
offers and knew I could play with the
best of the best in the country I knew
that even though I was a late bloomer
and didn't pass the eye test that I
could uh excel at the highest level it
just needed the opportunity to showcase
my skills and that underrated mindset is
part of my DNA forever so no matter how
many accolades and accomplishments I've
had still carry that as motivation and
inspiration to you know prove to myself
more than anybody that I'm capable of
doing you know great things on and off
the court that's the underrated mindset
when you told me when I went to Davidson
would I ever have a documentary about
this part of my life I would be like
what are you talking about what is what
does that even mean but now knowing that
uh you know all the great things that
have happened and everything that was
born you know in that experience that I
had those three years it's the perfect
title for the origin story of everything
that I've been able to accomplish why
was Stephen Curry drafted so late some
would say seven is not so late seven out
of 60. there are three other point
guards that were drafted ahead of me and
obviously you know over the last 15
years I've tried to excel at the highest
level and make that seventh Draft pick
status look really really low so it's
kind of a revisionist history a little
bit on that one but I love the fact that
seven is now seen as way too late
where did
Stephen Curry meet his wife I met Aisha
junior year of high school at our church
youth group so we didn't go to the same
high school didn't really date we're in
the same circle of friends and then
dated like about three or four years
later
and the rest is history Stephen Curry
best shots I mean the OKC shot a big
three and game six in the 2022 finals
there's a lot of them so that's nice
we're talking basketball in that golf I
had him very recently a hole-in-one at
the American Century Classic on the
seventh hole is 152 yards it was
pitching witch and then I had a nice
little 20-foot Eagle putt to win the
tournament to my first ever you know
tournament win there so I had some
really good golf ones too the Stephen
Curry play defense I love that that's a
hell of a question uh the answer is yes
but sometimes
Stephen Curry shoe size I wear a size 12
and a half sometimes with 13 depending
on the kicks any idea who might have the
biggest in the league probably in the
history league I would say Shaq but
right now probably either KD or Joel
embiid maybe just based off of sheer
size Stephen Curry night night uh that
was my little game clenching celebration
anytime you hit a big shot
it's kind of like put them to sleep you
know put the kids to bed it became kind
of the wave after the finals in 22 hit a
lot of different sports still showed
itself every once in a while so pretty
cool moment
alrighty will Stephen Curry be in the
Hall of Fame I sure hope so I hope
that's pretty much guaranteed at this
point not gonna slow me down at all to
acknowledge that but hopefully that's
pretty much guaranteed Stephen Curry
tips on shooting it all starts with
balance so if you look at the greatest
Shooters in the history of the league
nobody shoots the same as somebody else
so we've all kind of perfected our
mechanics and are able to repeat the
same release in the same shooting Tempo
form balance every single time we shoot
but it all starts in your feet if you
have bad feet bad balance you're never
going to be able to release the ball the
way that you want to and have the
accuracy and consistency that you need
to be called a great shooter so it all
starts with your with your feet Stephen
Curry lifestyle wow I don't even know
how to define the lifestyle of just
being an all-around great guy no I just
like to have fun I like to enjoy my life
enjoy the things I get to do be present
in the moment take some chances extend
your your your comfort zone a little bit
on and off cord on and off the course
family just trying to have fun and enjoy
the blessings that God's given me that's
the lifestyle Stephen Curry Legacy you
know being able to change the game and
you know what we stand for changing the
game for good A lot of the ways that the
game is played now I feel like I've had
a huge part in that how people see their
ability to be creative on the court
stretch their range stretch their
imagination but then also off the court
providing a lot of opportunity
inspiration for people to to find their
true potential in life and trying to be
a big inspiration in that part as well
did Stephen Curry beat in the NBA Finals
we beat Cleveland three times 15 17 and
18 and we beat Boston in the 22 finals
four and two in the finals we lost to
Cleveland once and we lost to Toronto
got to win something you lose some it's
all good is there a performance of those
four that you felt most proud of
definitely game four of the 2022 finals
that was a hostile environment and we
were down 2-1 we either win that to give
ourselves some life and have one of my
best games of my career considering the
magnitude of that moment for sure
Stephen Curry eye color I'm the green
eyed monster as my mom used to call me
when I was a little little kid so yeah
we have some good eyes on our family
Stefan Curry unanimous MVP that was an
unreal year it was the 73 and nine years
also the year we lost in the NBA Finals
to be
you know the first unanimous MVP winner
in NBA history was crazy there's been so
many amazing athletes that I've I'm
following their footsteps so it was
special I do remember exactly where I
was when they announced it I was sitting
right underneath the TV at my house and
Walnut Creek and the whole family went
crazy so very very special moment for
sure Stephen Curry half court shots is
hilarious because some people have sent
me the link of like there's a
compilation of all the half court shots
that I've made the funny part is I try I
practice all of them you know whenever
I'm in a gym it's how I end every
workout pretty much and most of the
shots that you see in the game it's not
the first time I've either taking or
making them it's just like to have fun
when I'm in the gym and that usually
involves kind of checking them from half
court every once in a while there's a
lot of people that uh you know when I
wait till right after the buzzer to
throw it up because if it goes in it's
really cool but if they miss it doesn't
count towards the stats I really don't
care what my percentage is because I'm
gonna keep shooting them Stephen Curry
records it sounds like I got a studio or
something like out here putting out all
the greatest and latest music now the
most special record I guess is the 2974
which is still now stretching into the
three thousands of three-pointers made
which I'm trying to keep stretching the
record there in the NBA history there's
been a lot of great shoes Reggie Miller
Ray Allen even my dad I hope to keep
pushing it where it's Untouchable but I
know how the game has changed so I'm
assuming that somebody's gonna be coming
behind and and we'll uh we'll challenge
it at some point but hopefully not
anytime soon
can Stephen Curry dunk I used to be able
to I definitely can you won't see it in
the games that often because now I'm in
the business of you know conserving you
know energy two points is two points as
they always say so take the layup
because I've definitely missed a bunch
of dunks I think you can look it up a
highlight reel of dunks that I've had in
my career which is cool I am 6'3 so I
should be able to get up there how does
Stephen Curry train you know I really
pride myself on the work that I put into
the game whether it's in the weight room
or you know my skill set on the court
conditioning and what they call the
Unseen hours I really proud myself in
the work ethic because that's the only
way that I can be successful it's the
gift that keeps on giving you got to
keep putting in the time to get the
results you do a lot of golf prep or
does this just come natural let's say if
I put in 100 hours on basketball and
probably about 10 hours of golf it's the
hardest sport in the game in the world
to try to to master I don't think
anybody has other than tiger and maybe
Jack Nicklaus I do obsess over it a lot
so I watch a lot of Swing videos
what is Stephen Curry's wingspan this is
a sour spot for me a lot of guys in NBA
have longer wingspans in their height
way better on defense can steal the ball
can block shots so there's a lot of guys
who are like six five six nine or six
ten wingspans I am the average 6'3 guy
with six three wingspans so nothing
remarkable there at all see what I got
where is Steph Curry on the scoring list
I want to say I'm like 48th or something
like that but I don't know where I'm at
was there anyone you felt significant
passing it sounds crazy because it was
it was a long time ago pops but my
my dad most of his career especially
towards the end and all the Milestones
that he had so to pass him the scoring
books is just you know something that's
special he played 16 years in the NBA
and that was always a goal of mine so
I'm entering year 15 I'm almost there
but I feel like I got a lot left just
trying to enjoy the experience in the
process
all right we got through all of those
boards there's some great questions some
weird ones in there too I actually did
learn a little bit about myself and
these questions too so until next time
we out